get your reservations for all of garden
and your big dumb wiener in bed because
we have one of the craziest elections
since now a historic moment that we can
now project the winner of the
presidential race Ryan Murphy's the
politician is in over the top take on
politics and a scathing satire on the
political system voter apathy and
political manipulation with outlandish
characters at times reminiscent of the
Coen brothers the first season of the
politician takes us into the cutthroat
world of high-school politics so we're
gonna take a look at its ending and what
it could mean for season two the final
episode feels like it really should be
the first episode of season 2 it's hard
to say it's really an ending but more of
a set up for next season were three
years into the future and the events of
Santa Barbara and the election are long
behind Peyton he's a student at NYU has
given up on his dream of becoming the
president attending Harvard and has
subsequently taken to the bottle this is
a completely different Peyton than the
one we saw in the first episode who
would stop at nothing to become
president but win at all costs I know
what my future is gonna be and I know
how to get there and I will not be
stopped infinity and sky have come to
visit and have to carry him back because
he's so drunk for a series that spent
much of its time focusing on infinity in
the dynamic with her mother this episode
leaves infinities arc for next season up
in the air we do know she's living off
the advance from her story but how
she'll play into season two is a mystery
her boyfriend Ricardo who is one of my
favorite characters is also in jail but
if he's released it could definitely
throw a wrench in Peyton's bid for New
York senator but we'll get into that in
a bit Peyton will find his dorming with
James his friend and political adviser
who backstabbed Peyton by sleeping with
Alice and when Peyton finds out Alice is
to be married to a man she doesn't truly
love named Thad he makes a last-ditch
effort to swear back it's also
interesting to note Peyton's third
roommate Kaiji I'm certain he wasn't
randomly put in there and that his
character will come into play next
season after all Peyton does know
Mandarin even though he got a d-minus on
his report card and was season 2
focusing on a Senate race it's likely
we're going to get bigger
political players like the Chinese
involved how Chi will be involved is
still up in the air but I'm certain this
was part of a set up that will be
exploited next season meanwhile the
episode spends most of its time setting
up Payton's political rival senator Dede
Standish and her overbearing chief of
staff Hadassah gold they're really
setting a pedasi as they main villan
next season especially through her
treatment and sense of entitlement in
her interactions with low-end staffers
like junior senator from Texas in turn
and even McAfee a girl who went from the
head of Payton's political campaign now
relegated to sending fliers in the mail
senator Standish hasn't been primary for
years she runs unopposed with political
aspirations beyond the Senate that's why
she's approached by the senator from
Texas to be his running mate in the
presidential election she accepts she's
become complacent her campaign office is
a relic from the 90s and there's no
energy surrounding her or her campaign
so when McAfee notices this she sees an
opportunity for Payton to reignite that
flame for political greatness his
ambition but as Payton says it was his
ambition that got him into this mess in
the first place I screwed up everything
in my life my ambition just poisoned
every decision but it's Payton's
realization of this that almost
completes his character arc for the
season
his ambition clouded his judgment he did
terrible things as a result of it hurt
himself and others and to mask the pain
of it he excessively drinks in a vain
effort to cope but to fully complete his
arc he must pick himself up and start
again now armed with the knowledge of
his past flaws it takes his friends to
motivate him to run but there's one
problem how the hell is he supposed to
take on a seasoned incumbent like Dede
Standish q Astrid she's moved to New
York after sending her father to jail
while on a catering gig she noticed
senator Standish and her love affair
with two men she's in a throuple armed
with this knowledge and mcafee belief
that if Payton focuses on a single
relatable issue he might just stand a
chance at taking down the senator but
what really makes Payton all-in is his
final talk with the ghosts of River
River provided the ultimate foil for
Payton whereas Payton was calculated
mechanical River was authentic from the
heart and grounded throughout the season
Payton is visited by rivers ghosts as a
means to have his character grow and
learn river kept him in check
after visiting Payton in the bar he
tells them that there's more honor in
defeat than an unused potential leading
Payton to agree to run against senator
Standish Alice upon hearing that Payton
is taking the plunge leaves her own
wedding in order to be by his side her
love for Payton is so strong she faked a
cheating scandal in order to boost
Payton's poll numbers for the high
school election it will be interesting
to see what lengths she's willing to go
for pain and the campaign next season
campaigns also happen to cost a lot of
money luckily there are a lot of places
Payton could look to bankroll his
campaign
Astra's family Alice's an arrangement
with his own father or even the Chinese
but what the show doesn't really delve
into that deeply is why Payton wants to
be President so deeply why has he spent
every waking moment to this one pursuit
the answer lies in his upbringing Payton
was adopted and never knew why his
biological parents abandoned him
what better way to gain a feeling of
acceptance than by winning an election a
way to prove that you are wanted I
wouldn't be surprised if Payton's true
birth parents came into the picture in
future episodes as well and here's a
crazy tinfoil hat conspiracy what if
Dede Standish is Payton's biological
mother that could be absolutely crazy
speaking of family will gwyneth paltrow
reprise her role as Payton's mother
she's off in Boonton which just so
happens to border Chinese controlled
Tibet yet another way the writers could
link China to Payton's campaign but what
I'm more curious about is how Payton's
campaign will differ from his high
school one will the team continue and
anything it takes approach to winning or
will it be more reserved seeing as how
this season had many over-the-top
elements my guess is that we'll be in
for more of the same this time with even
more at stake in what will happen to
Jessica Lange and will we see her return
as dusty Jackson when asked by
Entertainment Weekly if we'll see dusty
again she replied quote I don't think so
I mean Dusty's not one of those that has
a second act end quote
so it looks like this might be the last
we see of her finally I want to talk
about one of
more interesting episodes number 5 the
voter which almost exclusively follows
one character as they go through
Election Day it's this episode that
shines a light on voter apathy and the
feeling that our votes don't make a
difference affect us or that those who
are in charge simply don't have our
well-being at heart we follow Elliott
Beach Minh and apathetic undecided voter
who asked heard and Peyton tried to get
to vote for them they don't actually
care about him as a person they just
want his vote which speaks to what many
Americans believe in the 2016 election
almost half of eligible voters didn't
even vote when asked if he voted Elliott
says that his vote doesn't even matter
this is especially interesting because
we find out later from the principal
that Payton lost by two votes one that
could have been Elliott's and this girl
whose vote was suppressed because she
didn't have her student ID but at the
core of what the writers are trying to
say here is not that people are dumb for
not voting it's that the politicians in
charge treat them as votes and not as
people that no matter who they vote for
things won't change if we can instill in
them a reason to vote to get behind a
candidate maybe some real change can
happen the politician season two is
shaping up to be even bigger than season
one with a huge shift from high school
campaign to the US Senate with such a
huge shift it'll be interesting to see
where the new season goes and what this
could mean for our characters I hope you
enjoyed this video be sure to LIKE and
subscribe with the Belon as I have more
videos coming away you can also follow
me on Twitter at big story whitey
until next time remember daddy loves you
very much